[Music]
but as soon as we walked on the set
the dynamic between the three of us was
exactly the same as it was 30 years ago
it's as if these characters lived with
us for the last 30 years
it was not a difficult transition to
step back into those boots
very special to be part of something
that has become so meaningful in
people's lives
yes Salem we're back
I really wanted an actual backstory too
the Sanderson sisters happy 16th
birthday tribe and Hocus Pocus 2 we have
three young girls in Salem who are you
we have to Rally together against three
evil witches
these women are so talented and added
such a great layer to this whole
experience Hocus Pocus too does really
well like picking up where the first one
left off
it's a movie of friendship and these
friends accidentally bring back the
Sanderson sisters if we intend to live
past Sunrise we have to steal this so so
we'll wait can we talk about this
you know
I'm excited for the audience to see
Salem come back to life
this movie is so much fun because it
pays homage to the original movie while
being its own thing it was a real thrill
to come back and play these characters
[Music]
thank you
oh what fun we have
foreign